Bon, il se passe quelque chose de majeur démographiquement parlant.
Et il se pourrait qu’en dépassant le stade de 50% d’urbanisation
on arrive à un point de retournement économique. Le monde est désormais une carte de connectivité.
Il fut un temps où Paris, Londres et New-York étaient les 3 plus grandes villes du monde.
Ce que nous observons désormais c’est la fin de la montée en puissance de l’Ouest. C’est fini.
Les chiffres globaux sont édifiants.
Que se passe-t-il donc ? Et bien, les villages du monde se vident.
La question est : pourquoi ?
Et voici la vérité crue -- et l’air de la ville vous rend libre,
disait-on dans l’Allemagne de la renaissance. Donc les gens vont dans des lieux
comme Shanghai, mais la plupart vont dans des squats et des bidonvilles où l’esthétique donne le La.
Et ce ne sont pas vraiment des gens opprimés par la pauvreté.
Ce sont des gens qui sortent de la pauvreté aussi vite qu’ils le peuvent.
Ce sont les constructeurs dominants, et dans une large mesure, les designers dominants.
Ils ont forgé chez eux une infrastructure et une vie urbaines trépidantes.
Un sixième du PIB en Inde vient de Bombay.
Ils s’améliorent tout le temps, et dans quelques cas, le gouvernement leur vient en aide.
L’éducation est le principal changement qu'on peut voir dans les villes.
Que se passe-t-il dans les rues de Bombay ?
Al Gore le sait. En résumé, tout.
Il n’y a pas de chomâge dans les bidonvilles. Tout le monde travaille.
Un sixième de l’humanité se trouve là. Bientôt ça sera plus que ça.
Donc voilà la première chute de la petite histoire.
Les villes ont désamorcé la bombe démographique.
Et voilà la deuxième chute de la petite histoire.
Voilà des nouvelles du centre-ville. Voilà le tout remis en perspective.
Les étoiles ont brillé pour nous sur Terre pendant des milliards d’années.
Désormais nous brillons aussi en retour.
Merci.